un cours de percussions corporelles ça
débute par un échauffement sur des
djembés un apprentissage supplémentaires
pour ces musiciens qui pratiquent tous
un autre instrument violon saxophone
batterie
alors il faut trouver son rythme c'est
plus notre prof qui est qu'il invente et
non après on essaye de s'adapter dès
fois on corrige un peu on est toujours
en train de faire deux trois petites
modifications même le jour du concert on
peut faire une modification qui fait que
je ne pense plus j'apprends à vivre avec
les autres et pas à côté des autres
c'est vraiment tout un travail de groupe
un travail d'ensemble j'ai un groupe qui
est très hétérogène ils n'ont pas tous
les mêmes âgées n'ont pas tous le même
niveau il faut quand même réussir à
noter un morceau ensemble
le but du jeu c'est d'arriver à
construire quelque chose ensemble à
partager quelque chose ensemble et puis
surtout à faire de la musique ensemble
et pour ça il faut réussir à a pas
imposer ses idées par rapport à votre à
écouter les autres à a essayé de aussi
de trouver sa place dans le groupe
les percussions le chant la danse la
discipline est complète et elle ouvre à
ces jeunes musiciens les portes de la
comédie musicale
[Musique]
ici la partition celle enthousiaste
compositeur julien joubert qui l'a
écrite
[Musique]
répulsion aux corporate c'est énorme
c'est à dire que en fait on se rend pas
compte
je ne sais pas quel est le moyen pour
comprendre qu'on a un corps parfois
c'est simplement par le chant et on
arrive à comprendre que le corps et
chantant mais de temps en temps c'est
par un autre biais et la percussion
corporelle c'est formidable pour un
certain nombre d'enfants ou même
d'adultes qui font que grâce à cette
action physique alors ça débloque tout
un tas de trucs et notamment le champ
pourquoi opérer ensemble et ça nous
permet aussi de s'entendre et aussi
quelques voix se faire des amis et de
rigoler et de s'amuser
[Musique]
cette création musicale leïla et ses
amis musiciens vont interpréter bientôt
au milieu de tableau du musée des
beaux-arts un numéro assurément
jubilatoire
[Musique]